Щосуботи під Києвом на території закинутого заводу лунають постріли і військові команди.
Там тренуються резервісти територіальної оборони міста Києва.
Серед них - Марта Юзьків, менеджерка фармацевтичної компанії.
51-річна жінка живе у передмісті Києва, має родину і любить займатися домашнім господарством.
Але так само охоче раз на тиждень виїжджає зі свого затишного будинку на військові тренування.
Я не знаю, чи буде війна, але однозначно хочу бути до неї готовою.
Тому це - найоптимальніший варіант для мирного населення, яке не може бути на фронті, на Сході, просто бути готовим чинити опір.
До лав 130-го батальйону тероборони Києва Марта вступила ще у квітні,
коли Росія вперше стягнула свої війська до українського кордону.
Відтоді щосуботи вона тренується разом з кількома десятками таких самих резервістів.
Я думаю, у всіх однакова мотивація: бути десь корисними, бути підготовленими.
Вона у всіх коливається від зовсім маленького - захистити свій будинок, свою сім'ю,
до більшого - захистити своє місто, свою країну.
Більш-менш ми всі однодумці в цьому питанні.
І ніхто не хоче бути неготовим, ніхто не хоче жити в окупації.
Навесні Марта уклала контракт про проходження служби у військовому резерві.
А отже, добровільно стала на військовий облік.
Незабаром військовозобов'язаних жінок має побільшати.
Бібліотекарки, журналістки, піарниці, маркетологині, соціальні працівниці -
це далеко не вичерпний перелік спеціальностей, представниці яких тепер підпадають під військовий облік.
Ідеться загалом про представниць 35 фахових напрямків і десятків професій віком від 18 до 60 років.
При чому винятків не буде ні для вагітних, ні для мам з малолітніми дітьми,
якщо вони представниці оновленого списку професій.
У багатьох це викликало обурення і нерозуміння.
Я вважаю, що хай чоловіки воюють, а ми не повинні, ми ж жінки…
Українська жінка ніколи не воювала, і я думаю, що їй не хочеться воювати.
Вона завжди була вдома, була берегинею домашнього вогнища.
Це маразм повний. Вона побіжить кудись чи на збори буде їздити? Це маячня!
Це тільки Зеленський міг придумати таку нісенітницю.
Я вважаю, що до цього питання варто підходити більш серйозно, ніж як вирішила наша влада.
Жінки в армії потрібні, але не так спонтанно, як вони вирішили.
На сайті президента України з'явилася петиція "Знущання над жінками!
Не повинні усі жінки, які мають спеціальність та/або професію, бути військовозобов'язаними!"
Петиція за 4 дні зібрала 25 тисяч підписів. І тепер її мусить розглянути президент.
Авторка петиції аргументувала своє невдоволення так:
У міноборони запевняють: перехідний період передбачений - жінки мають стати на облік до 2023 року.
Лише після цього почнуть штрафувати.
У міністерстві також наголошують: військовий облік і військова служба - це різні речі.
Мета обліку - отримати чітку картину щодо дефіцитних військових спеціальностей.
У київському воєнкоматі наголосили, що ситуація для жінок на обліку зміниться тільки за умови воєнного часу.
Механізм ставання на військовий облік такий:
упродовж 2022 року представниці розширеного переліку професій повинні повідомити свого працедавця,
написати заяву до територіального центру комплектування - так тепер називають воєнкомати,
зібрати документи, пройти медогляд і звернутися до ТЦК з усіма паперами.
Планується, що військовозобов'язані жінки проходитимуть збори виключно за бажанням.
І навіть у разі воєнних дій міноборони не відправлятиме їх зі зброєю на фронт.
Вони мають допомагати армії інакше - працювати за спорідненими військово-обліковими спеціальностями.
На думку резервістки Марти Юзьків, у новому наказі міноборони щодо змін у військовому обліку жінок немає нічого страшного.
Це рішення буде навіть корисним для України.
Для воюючої країни мати облік всіх людей, які можуть бути мобілізовані в разі потреби,
або хоча би мати перелік, з якої кількості вони можуть обирати, - це потрібно.
Тому цей наказ і цей крок я вважаю правильним.
Можливо, не зовсім вчасним і не зовсім правильно поданим,
але рано чи пізно його треба було робити, і це насправді правильний крок.
Марта вважає, що жінки в армії потрібні. Це відчувається навіть на тренуваннях.
Я би сказала, що витривалість у жінок у чомусь більша.
І це ж англійські психологи ставлять поліцейських у парі чоловік-жінка,
тому що реакція в екстремальних ситуаціях у них буде різна, і вони будуть доповнювати одне одного.
Тому я поділяю точку зору, що це правильна комбінація, і жінки повинні бути в армії, щоб компенсувати.
Марта надихнула своїм прикладом старшого сина і чоловіки - ті також вступили до лав тероборони.
Наразі в ЗСУ проходить службу 31 757 жінок.